this facility is an abandoned cold
factory which we repurposed into a
bitcoin mining center that draws clean
power from the mag river
[Music]
bitdigital is one of the world's largest
bitcoin mining companies that says they
are committed to sustainability in an
industry that has been criticized for
its reliance on cheap power and fossil
fuels the bitcoin mining computers
running in this facility are powered
almost entirely by hydroelectric clean
power
a bitcoin mining rig doesn't pull
anything out of the ground instead it is
usually made up of thousands of
computers specially built to run the
complex calculations that maintain the
cryptocurrency's network
the bitcoin algorithm demands increasing
amounts of computational power to
validate transactions
if it were a country its annual
estimated carbon footprint would be
comparable to new zealand
the reason it's important to be
sustainable in this space is because
bitcoin mining is a very energy
intensive industry and we believe we're
quickly approaching a point in time
where it will no longer be acceptable
for a publicly traded miner to operate
on fossil fuels
and bitcoin's power consumption this
year will likely be a whopping 91
terawatt hours roughly equivalent to
pakistan's according to bloomberg nef
but not everyone believes that bitcoin
mining has a significant environmental
impact
i personally believe that the arguments
against
bitcoin miners with respect to the
environment is somewhat disingenuous
because if you look at the existing
financial system the banks the atms the
trees that need to be cut down for paper
dollars and so on that requires a
massive carbon footprint and that's much
larger than the footprint that's caused
by bitcoin mining
in may china imposed a ban on all crypto
transactions due to its ties to fraud
money laundering and excessive energy
usage
up until then almost two-thirds of
bitcoin mining took place in china where
a severe power crisis is affecting the
production of commodities like aluminum
and steel
the ban has forced miners to leave
behind china's cheap coal powered
electricity and has created a global
rush to find new sources of inexpensive
reliable power
that's why bitdigital opened their new
facility in buffalo new york right by
the niagara falls
people know niagara falls is one of the
great wonders of the world and that
water has been harnessed to generate
an enormous amount of electricity that
powers this region this region used to
be an industrial powerhouse a hundred
years ago this was one of the most
important industrial cities in america
and one of the reasons industry flocked
here is because of the plentiful power
in the early 1900s
buffalo was actually called the city of
light because there was so much abundant
electricity here generated from the
niagara river
investors are still concerned about the
sustainability of bitcoin mining
there's a huge esg movement happening
with respect to investing in companies
esg meaning environmental social and
governmental and that's why we're very
motivated financially to find clean
sources of power so we can attract these
kinds of investors
bitdigital has already mined 3 000
bitcoin
and we want to be a model to other
bitcoin miners on how to profit with
respect to bitcoin mining but at the
same time not cause damage to the earth
you